Film and Science
Science has been arguably one of the most
influential forces in modern society. But
it’s a subject that is rarely the focus
of fictional works.
Science Fiction exists as a genre, but the
influence of science is often contained to
constructing the setting for an otherwise
traditional story. Rarely are scientists and
the scientific process given the spotlight.
Often science fiction is examining the outcome
of a specific technology, science applied,
instead of the scientific process involved
with discovering or producing that technology.
Black Mirror, modern science fiction-Twilight
Zone, is hardly concerned with the actual
science of what it presents, merely the social
and individual ramifications of those technologies,
sometimes to the level of caricature.
In fact much of how science and scientists
are presented in film involves some level
of caricature. We often see the scientist
as crazed madman [Back to the Future]. Or
science as voluntarily or involuntarily spawning
some monster or hero.
[Spiderman, Captain America, Godzilla]
Consider the common theme of superheroes or
villain created in a lab by accident. Science
is an out of control force, directed by irresponsible
scientists, and whether what it produces is
a force for good or evil is a product of chance.
Even when the scientists creation of a hero
is more measured and intentional, [Iron Man]
that scientist is presented as a self-absorbed,
egomaniac.
Scientist often exist merely to spout exposition
when needed, [Jurassic Park] or as the pawns
of those who hold the real power.
Even films that seem to give science a closer
examination, they may paying a lot of lip
service to it’s name, but they often end
up casting it aside in favor of other answers
to the story’s central conflict.
I’m not saying that all of these films are
bad because they portray science in this way.
But why is this? Why is the scientific process
so often overlooked in film?
Aldous Huxley in his essay “Literature and
Science” examines the divide between science
and the literary arts.
Talking about authors he says They have not
been greatly interested in the science as
a set of logically coherent hypotheses validated
operationally by experiment and dispassionate
observation. And the in the field of applied
science their concern has been mainly with
the social and psychological consequences
of advancing technology, very little with
it’s working or it’s underlying technology.
Huxley’s words could be describing the tech
film that is fascinated with the interpersonal
drama surrounding the creation of a technology,
more than the the tech itself. But you might
say, “logically coherent hypotheses” and
“dispassionate observation” are not the
grounds for great stories. Stories are about
passion, feeling, and emotion. You might be
right.
Huxley goes on to describe how both science
and literature use language to describe things.
But it’s the nature of what each needs to
describe that’s different. The language
of science seeks for clarity and purity in
terms of specificity. It seeks to describe
what Huxley calls “public experiences”
or those experiences that are external and
in that way shared by individuals.
The literary artist takes a different approach
focusing on “private experiences”
“The world with which literature deals is
the world in which human beings are born and
live and finally die; the world in which they
love and hate, in which they experience triumph
and humiliation, hope and despair…”
The differing goals present a challenge when
presenting science in film. Can those two
come together? Reconciling the two is no easy
task. But it’s one that Huxley thought was
possible.
One early step, something that Huxley suggests
to authors in his essay, is to include more
relevant science within the work itself.
And you can see this happening more and more
frequently. Multiverse theory has been explicitly
influential on certain storytellers. For interstellar,
Christopher Nolan drew heavily on cutting
edge science to produce accurate visualizations
of a black hole.
But fear might creep into the filmmaker that
the science included in the film will become
outdated, making the film feel irrelevant
in a way it might not if the details were
kept more vague. Or a filmmaker might worry
that those details will be inaccurate, making
the story feel immediately irrelevant to those
who are more scientifically knowledgable.
And so filmmakers focus on portraying and
discussing the emotional, philosophical, and
relational fallout that the effects of science
and technology have had and rarely focus on
the science itself. Or sidestep the science
in favor of a pseudo-metaphysical solution.
But this doesn’t account for the entire
separation. Huxley’s essay was partially
written in response to a lecture given by
scientist and Novelist C. P. Snow called “The
Two Cultures” in which he described a cultural
divide between scientists and authors. At
that time there was little crossover between
the fields of professional artist and scientist.
And it makes sense, the level of dedication
needed to be a good scientist and a good artist
are high enough that taking on both is unrealistic
for most. I think the cultural separation
that Snow observed is slowly closing as Huxley
hoped it would, literature now has many good
examples of the gap being bridged, and recently
film has given us some stories where science
itself has played a larger role. Let’s examine
a few of those:
Primer
Primer imagines the creation of a time machine,
as if it were invented in a garage like the
personal computer. Much attention is payed
to the progression of decisions and ideas
that lead to the discovery of the actual machine
and subsequent tests. It’s a rare moment
when the process of discovery itself takes
center stage ahead of character development.
Primer’s depiction of science can also help
us see that the issue is not always that most
movies don’t accurately depict science,
but that most movies don’t attempt to depict
the process at all.
Regardless of how dubious the science in Primer
might be, the attention it gives to the process
of invention is unique. And the fact that
the writer and director Shane Carruth is an
Engineer-turned Filmmaker, is no surprise.
The Martian
The Martian might be the film that does the
best job of bridging the divide between science
and film. The movie itself is interested
in science, much of the science shown in the
film is accurate. Science become the hero
of the story, the scientist the person who
is able to overcome adversity and triumph.
The Fountain
The Fountain doesn’t depict much science
itself, but it’s an unique film in that
it’s almost completely about a scientist
and the act of science itself. Instead of
turning the scientist into an adventurer,
[Indiana Jones] or presenting spirituality
as something that overcomes science. It uses
those images to show science as a spiritual
endeavor and an adventure on it’s own. Instead
of showing love as the thing that works when
science has failed, love is the very thing
that motivates the scientific act.
These films show us ways that the divide can
be bridged, and I think there’s plenty of
room for more of this type of exploration.
One response I’ve seen to this discussion
is that the reason for the lack of depicted
science may have to do with the mundane nature
of the majority of scientific endeavors. But
I don’t buy the theory, filmmakers are great
at making otherwise boring things appear interesting.
Most of politics is boring and dull, and yet
we’ve often found exciting and entertaining
ways to depict the political process.
I’m not insinuating that science is superior
to things like human ingenuity and love. These
very things are often what fuel the progression
of science. Perhaps the romanticism of art
works as a check and balance against the threat
of scientific hubris. You can see the less-than-positive
images of the scientist shifting as society’s
fears about what it might produce change.
As the ringing the bomb left in culture’s
ears is fading, our focus turns to new concerns.
The dialogue between Film and Science might
be more important than we think. I’ve been
focusing science’s influence on film, but
it goes both ways. Science fiction films make
it into scientific papers from time to time,
and science fiction plays a role in shaping
the kind of scientific development and technology
that society comes to want and expects.
Research suggests that cinematic depictions
of space travel helped shaped public opinion
about it’s viability, helping make it possible
to fund those endeavors.
Science isn’t going to become any less influential
in the future, and finding more accurate and
nuanced ways to tell stories about it certainly
couldn’t hurt… even attempting to tell
those stories at all as has so rarely been
done is a noble endeavor.
This video was largely inspired by Aldous
Huxley’s essay, and I’ve been a little
obsessed with Huxley’s writing lately. His
book Brave New World is an essential read
and I’m happy to say you can get it for
free as and Audiobook when you use my link
www.audible.com/thomasflight or text “thomasflight”
to five hundred five hundred and sign up for
a 30-day trial.
I love Audible and I’m happy to have them
sponsoring this video. I always hear people
talk about how great audiobooks are for commutes
and workouts, and they are, but they compliment
so many activities, make your summer better
by pairing some great audiobooks with a hike,
some time on the beach or a road trip.
When you sign up for audible you get a book
a month, For your first book I’m recommending
Brave New World. Huxley sets the story in
a dystopian future, but instead of highlighting
the danger of a government imposed dystopia
like Orwell shows us in 1984, Huxley shows
us a dystopia that the inhabitants unwittingly
welcomed upon themselves. It’s a story about
technology that is absolutely relevant to
today. Whatever book you choose is yours to
keep, that’s something I love about Audible,
the books you get are yours forever, sometimes
I’ve gone back and re-listened to books
I really enjoyed two or three times.
So use my link http://www.audible.com/thomasflight
or text “thomasflight” to five hundred
five hundred to get a free book and 30-day
trial.
I’m listening to audiobooks all the time,
so if you have any recommendations, let me
know in the comments!